un emploi et trouver plus de soutien et
un pro avec un sac balancé somme
barre de décharge Veselov airat
donc encore une fois je répète ce que j'ai dit à propos de
divers types de soi-disant étranges
agent
et pour les gens qui se défendent
positionné comme une opposition systémique i
déjà répondu à vos collègues dans mon
sende bien, apparemment ce sont les lois du genre qui
doit être dit directement, comme pour répondre
votre question s'il vous plaît j'aimerais
je vais le refaire
les États-Unis ont adopté une loi
selon laquelle les États-Unis ont annoncé que
soutiendra certains
organisations politiques en Russie
en même temps
a déclaré la Fédération de Russie frag
ont déclaré publiquement qu'ils allaient
freiner le développement de la russie, la question est de savoir
la même organisation
exilés politiques que je suis tous les deux
autres membres de la communauté occidentale
devrait être soutenu en Russie
s'ils sont encore et nous payons clairement
que nous sommes aussi comme les américains des années 30
les ont déclarés agents étrangers, mais
le travail n'est pas interdit ils peuvent travailler
déclaration par un agent étranger
met fin à l'activité d'un
organisations
si l'organisation a un extrémiste
le personnage est une autre histoire et c'est tout
dont vous avez dit publiquement l'organisation
appelé à des émeutes
impliqué publiquement ce qui est illégal dans
activités de rue juvéniles
il est interdit par les lois russes et
donné des instructions publiques sur la manière
préparer des cocktails
Molotov pour les utiliser
contre les forces de l'ordre
tout en exposant l'installation
données de police amérique complètement
a récemment fait face à une situation difficile
événements après les événements connus sur
après le meurtre
afro-américain et
créer tout un mouvement de vies noires
Matt et moi ne le ferons pas maintenant
je veux juste faire un commentaire
c'est ce qu'on a vu des pogroms
ce que vous avez vu enfreindre la loi et ainsi de suite
encore et encore nous sympathisons
américains et américains
mais nous ne voulons pas que cela se produise
notre territoire et fera tout pour
pour empêcher cela
et une sorte de peur ici n'est absolument pas
et s'il vous plaît
les deux paires club alliance dpm fazil
subvention aizen au site et à la dynamo puis
acheter signifie savoir qui sera tué
ou ils vous jetteront en prison avec politique
conditions
les gens sont entrés au congrès américain après les élections
400 man allume portiv 400 jack
des affaires pénales ont été ouvertes et ils sont menacés
jusqu'à 20 ans d'emprisonnement et peut
avoir moins de 25 ans les déclare internes
les terroristes sont accusés d'un certain nombre d'autres
70 crimes a été arrêté immédiatement
après ces événements et seulement 30 d'entre eux avant
est toujours en état d'arrestation
sur quelle base il n'est pas clair parce qu'aucun des
fonctionnaires de l'État à ce sujet
n'informe pas l'un des participants
plusieurs des participants y sont morts
le flic vient de lui tirer dessus sur place
elle n'a pas menacé la police
armes dans de nombreux pays tout arrive
la même chose que nous voulons encore
mettre l'accent sur
nous sympathisons avec le fait que
s'est passé aux États-Unis
mais nous ne voulons pas laisser la même chose
la plupart nous sont arrivés